do you ever get the feeling
you're being watched
what if every move you make is recorded
you didn't see any security cameras
and that's the point what if the
military deployed
a million nano drones
insect surveillance robots capable of
watching your every move
what kind of missions would they perform
would it make the world safer
or start a dystopian nightmare
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the military
deployed a million nano drones
drones are remotely piloted aircraft
they belong to the broad category of
unmanned aircraft systems or
uas's depending on the mission they're
built for
they can be as big as airplanes or as
tiny
as insects enter the black hornets
each black hornet drone weighs about 33
grams
and is about 17 centimeters long that's
five centimeters longer than a dragonfly
a black hornet can fly at up to 21
kilometers per hour and
has a two kilometer range during its
25-minute flight time
and for these tiny spies their missions
are all about surveillance and
reconnaissance
so what would it be like if the military
unleashed a million of these
well if they see military action they
could be used for
safer reconnaissance missions
you could send in the drones without
having to put humans at risk
it would also give the military the
upper hand when it comes to
situational awareness using the tiny spy
drones
military personnel will be able to see
around obstacles or
peak inside windows before getting near
a target area
they would be able to get all relevant
information before confronting a
situation
and in doing so they could save a lot of
lives that
could potentially be lost due to lacking
data
but what about using nano drones in
non-combat situations
well you'd be looking at a huge upgrade
in surveillance this could be helpful in
stopping crime in
large event areas let's say the drones
are
able to identify everyone who's at an
event
if things go south and something bad
happens
they would be able to identify potential
suspects
the goal would be to prevent horrible
situations like
mass shootings from happening could
these little guys
be our silent guardians well
you could also use a swarm of nano
drones to help find missing people
if someone is lost or even worse
kidnapped
the areas that they were in could be
searched much more quickly and
effectively
instead of having mobs of people
scouring the area
several drones could be given a chunk of
territory to search
if they launched a 1 million nano drone
search party
it would cover a lot of ground
imagine a locust swarm but it's live
cameras
instead of insects and
that's the thing while a million
undetectable surveillance cameras
could be useful do we even want them
around
what if the line between security and
stalking got a little blurry
would you want a camera the size of a
dragonfly to be
streaming a live feed of your daily
activities to military operatives
it's very possible that some groups
would form
to resist military surveillance people
might start to try and take them down
fighting a george orwell inspired
surveillance state
so could we really be looking at a world
with
a million nano drones watching our every
move
yes and no while
it might be plausible that the military
would have one million nano drones
it's a lot less likely that they'd
release them all at the same time
[Music]
a swarm of drones kind of defeats the
whole point of being stealthy
as for drone technology it's only going
to get
better and better think about how much
cell phones have improved in recent
years now everyone can enjoy the freedom
of a personal cellular phone
you can make a call anywhere contrary to
the fears of people who believe
the military would use drones to surveil
the public
the current use for these drones would
be reconnaissance missions overseas
but only time will tell how these tiny
spies get used
that amount of information is a little
too much for me
what about you what if you had access to
more than just the feeds of the nano
drones
what if you held the holy grail of
information in your hands
what if you in all your wisdom
control the internet
well that's a story for another
what if